alguna vez todos normalizamos frases
frente a los demás creyendo que son
inofensivas sin ser lo suficientemente
conscientes que son frases que nos
separan y que son racistas os voy a
poner algún ejemplo
vaya a pelo de gitana llevas uff
ni me hables llevo todo el día
trabajando como un negro eso eso que no
te funciona es tan malo que debe ser de
los chinos o suena en verdad
las utilizamos de manera cotidiana
siendo modelos lingüísticos para la
sociedad de generación en generación
pero sobre todo para los niños y de
alguna manera estamos cooperando en una
educación con una perspectiva radical
creyendo unos que unos somos mejores que
otros vamos a profundizar en el año 2016
participé en la universidad isabel
primera de burgos sobre un trabajo de
atención a la diversidad del alumnado
allí debíamos reflexionar sobre un vídeo
que tuvo una gran repercusión en mexico
contra el racismo
este era una réplica del famoso
experimento que llevaron en los años 30
en eeuu los psicólogos mami clerc y
kenneth clair
en los años 30 donde se le preguntaba a
los niños ya las niñas frente a un
muñeco bleu blanco y un muñeco negro con
cual se identificaban
cual preferían y cuál era el bueno y el
malo
podemos estar de acuerdo y darle
diferentes lecturas al test es verdad
que no profundiza sobre la
individualidad de los niños no puede
explicar el fenómeno y de alguna manera
condiciona a los niños en elegir entre
uno y otro
pero es cierto que todos los adjetivos
positivos recaían sobre el muñeco blanco
y el muñeco negro era el mal
lo curioso y lo absurdo es que este
experimento se realizó en méxico en el
año 2011 y no encontraron en ninguna
tienda ni ninguna juguetería un muñeco
negro tuvieron que comprar uno blanco
pintarlo quitarle los ojos azules y
cambiarlos por marrón
es verdad que la actualidad hemos ido
avanzando un poco en juegos más
inclusivos e incluso rompiendo
estereotipos de género por suerte en las
decisiones de las propias familias en
las jugueterías en las escuelas queda
mucho por hacer sobre todo en los
famosos catálogos de jugueterías donde
no hay una visibilidad normalizada y
encontramos estos muñecos con trajes
típicos tradicionales
parafernalia que hace que al niño no se
puede identificar con situaciones
cotidianas
pero a mí como maestra en ese momento
volviendo al vídeo me movió por dentro
sobre todo ver a niños negros eligiendo
el muñeco blanco por miedo a que el
negro este mal
sin ánimo de replicar otra vez el
experimento pero sí con la curiosidad de
saber qué era lo que pasaba a mi
alrededor cogí de mi aula dos muñecos y
realice las mismas preguntas a veinte
niños aquí en valencia entre 4 y 8 años
con la premisa que uno se puede
identificar con lo que más se le parece
pero porque otra vez el muñeco negro era
el malo
ya no como maestra sino como madre como
educadora dije algo algo algo estamos
haciendo mal algo tengo que hacer y por
eso construye un material didáctico algo
tan sencillo como un cuento que se puede
utilizar tanto en el aula pero también
en casa
y el color negro entra al aula lo
añadimos al arco iris lo asociamos a
cosas positivas como el chocolate que a
todos nos encanta es un color elegante
pintamos con él
y dada la repercusión y la aceptación de
los coles
al año siguiente decido dar un paso más
y escribo sobre otro color que también
crea controversia en el aula y es el
color carne
cuál es el color carne si todos tenemos
diferentes tonalidades de piel
como docentes debemos trazar proyectos
que nazcan desde el diálogo colectivo
respetando el interés de los niños que
puedan experimentar pero sobre todo que
puedan identificarse sin miedo y
sentirse seguros
bajo estas premisas nace la experiencia
educativa un book tour para la paz con
el objetivo de perfilar escuelas de paz
promoviendo un desarrollo local y global
pero sobre todo creando espacios de
igualdad activa y entendiendo está
atención a la diversidad abordando la
diversidad como un valor como un valor
que nos enriquece
la experiencia consiste en que el centro
recibe 30 lápices de las diferentes
tonalidades de la piel y el material
educativo que durante tres semanas
deberán trabajar de forma libre talleres
actividades jornadas solidarias patios
inclusivos utilizando un lenguaje
inclusivo
'vamos creatividad el poder y al
finalizar se lo envían al colegio
siguiente para continuar el tour por el
país
en la actualidad 20 centros de españa
participan de esta experiencia en la
etapa de educación infantil primera y
primer y segundo ciclo etapa primaria un
instituto de formación profesional de la
familia infantil donde están los futuros
educadores escuelas rurales centros de
difícil desempeño y también esta
experiencia está implementada en
latinoamérica en escuelas de argentina y
uruguay y colombia
con la gran idea de construir un
claustro de ideas para trabajar la paz
en todo el sistema educativo con un rol
activo de la comunidad educativa que
somos los profesores nuestros alumnos y
sus familias
vivimos en un mundo lingüístico
interactuamos constantemente creando
realidades y posicionándonos frente a
ella utilizamos el lenguaje como
mediador social pero justamente la
normalización de las expresiones crean
prejuicios y estereotipos y le dan voz a
esta prejuicios que nos creemos libres
vuelvo con ejemplos
hoy tuve un día negro esto es una
merienda de negros hay los panchitos
deja hacer el indio
os suena en verdad
podemos entre todos cambiar revalorizar
el poder de la palabra su fuerza su
esencia su impacto esto se hace desde la
reflexión en ese momento estaremos de
verdad educando valores y educando desde
edades tempranas educar es una
responsabilidad de todos de todas las
personas que luchamos por un mundo mejor
que nos movilizamos por las injusticias
que intentamos dar nuestra mejor versión
cada día
y se ahora la palabra paz o suena utopía
os digo que no que se encuentra
justamente detrás de estos pequeños
gestos
si dejamos de educar en la competencia
en ser los mejores y empezamos a educar
en la aceptación en la cooperación en la
tolerancia en la pluralidad toda acción
tendrá una repercusión mucho más
positiva creando sus sociedades más
justas y libres
construyamos un mundo donde la
diferencia no sea motivo de desprecio
educar para la paz es concebir que a
través del desarrollo de los valores
siendo modelos exista la posibilidad de
una humanidad mejor muchas gracias
[Aplausos]